this week's summit of the americas takes
place amid continuing global supply
chain problems which president joe biden
will address at the port of los angeles
on friday this is really a spectacular
golden opportunity economic policy
analysts say the solution to those
problems lies in a concerted effort to
shift manufacturing and shipping away
from asia to neighbors of the u.s the
so-called friendshiring of supply chains
we could be talking about several
millions of jobs that could move into
those countries linked to supply chains
and that would be
transformative in those economies but
unlinking the existing supply chain
would not be easy
will require both the hard
infrastructure and soft infrastructure
and what do i mean by soft
infrastructure governments the policy
the trade policies would have to align
to adopt the new ways of looking at
things
relations between the u.s and countries
like mexico whose president has decided
not to attend the summit are tense
even if the political goodwill for more
trade integration could be found the job
of building a vast industrial
infrastructure and port facilities would
take many years and hundreds of billions
of dollars but if french shoring were
realized it would have benefits far
beyond improving the fragile supply
chain it could reduce poverty and
migration curtail criminal gangs and
narcotics trafficking create good jobs
with good labor conditions
environmental security and that means
you'll employ workers who would then be
much less inclined to decide they have
to get out and migrate to the united
states or join a local
drug trafficking gang the time experts
say is now companies are already talking
about doing it
right there is a serious conversation in
the boardroom
how do we
diversify our supply chain how do we
make it shorter so they're much more
effective
in terms of the cost resiliency and
sustainability and america has a great
opportunity to take advantage of this
momentum because if we don't do it now
when will we
reconfiguring supply chains could be a
potential win-win for the u.s and its
neighbors but would require political
will and a level of trust that at the
moment doesn't seem to exist
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles